hello everybody brian is draining his
huge hog right now so this is me just
doing the dates cuz Brian's not on the
road cuz he's an actor
he's shooting his goldberg show and he's
not doing stand-up right now but I am
I'm in Dallas in two weeks out of sim
prob Dallas Texas that is November 14th
through the 16th after that I'm in Salt
Lake City wise guys my favorite clubs in
the world wise guys November 21st
through the 23rd and then December
weekend froggy in December real Road dog
style Kansas City December 6 through the
7th New Jersey bananas bananas December
12 through the 13th then the big boy
Bart a go or got the Borgata casino
Atlantic City one night only once your
only December 14th get your tickets
right now then I close out December
Oklahoma City casino one night only
December 27th get your tickets tief at
kake.com
what's up kids you know the holidays are
coming up and some of you guys just let
yourselves go cuz the holidays well
don't get in shape be a keto kid take
the guessing out of the game now before
like man a Mayan ketosis am I not maybe
I'm gonna prick my finger and drop blood
on this device to figure out if I'm
ketosis maybe I'm gonna do this man we
do take all the guessing away get keto
that's K ey T oh the makers of keto
breath sensors and keto premium are the
most accurate consistent and first-ever
user-friendly Bluetooth breathalyzers
and apps for your iPhone or Android you
know I'm saying
either way it's on your phone now it's
on your freaking phone the breath sensor
calculates a one to eight level of
ketosis for you keto kids out there on
your app it's on your phone now it's so
dang easy the keto breath sensor is just
$99 and provides keto level readings as
well as access to the ketose upcoming
food products with the app for only $8 a
month users can subscribe to keto
premium for access to videos articles
recipes here's my favorite part
restaurant guides so when you go to
restaurant you're like is this keto what
should I
eating what's healthy how many calories
all that they let you know now keto
premium also unlocks the keto code all
right so it's food and recipes that
allows you guys to quickly determine
what is in the keto program feature over
ten thousand color-coded foods and
recipes it's the simplest way to find
healthy recommendations that cater to
your needs
alright keto breast sensor and Premium
Subscription are available at get keto
that's GE t ke YT o comm size fighter
the keto app is available for both
Android and your iPhones just search in
the App Store for keto enter promo code
fighter for 20% off your first purchase
October is almost over knuckleheads did
you get sober October I think that's
what they caught how about the no
November that's right don't stop the
health cake and it's not too late you
can start any month forget October it's
just the name it's just a name man if
you want to get in shape if you're
looking for a way to track everything
you do I'm telling you there's no better
device and if you've been falling my
friends Tom Segura Bert Kreischer
Ari Shaffir Joe Rogan they're in there
sober October competition they're using
whoop they're using whoop it's a little
strap goes right on your wrist it's not
a big deal and it calculates everything
you need whoop is a performance tool
first and foremost you get the whoop
strap little strap which is a heartrate
monitor that measures your heart rate
ready 100 times per second 24/7 and what
is it what's gonna do what's gonna do
with all those heart rate readings well
it's gonna measure your recovery looks
at heart rate and let you know you rest
on heart rate your sleep quality your
strain how hard are you going in the
paint in your workout you know exactly
with woop you know exactly and it's well
documented on here sometimes I thought a
thousand calories we went you're burning
six hundred fat boy not a thousand don't
need extra four hundred calories that's
important it also measures your sleep
how good a sleep are you getting some
nights I'm like oh I got eight hours
whoops like yes you have four and a half
dummy all right so you know exactly what
you're getting
whoomp has provided you guys 30 hours
off their first purchase with
code fighter just go to whoop calm wh oo
p.com that's wh oo p calm use the code
fighter at checkout save $30 and
optimize the way you train all right
let's do this Brendan it's Monday time
it is I'm feeling good are you people at
brand for coming out you were in traffic
here's the text I got you know hold on
hours no no in traffic for what time is
it it says I was trapped for two and a
half hours two and half hours because I
lays on fire everybody I got this I got
well I peed in a bottle Brian he did and
I'm in studio and he peed in a pure leaf
brewed tea bottle but it looks like the
party it does I would drink it you drink
it you fill that up cuz I thought I'd
that's not enough for mine you don't
realize how much peepee brings out doing
fellas I was in traffic and I'm like I'm
gonna piss my pants yeah on PCH I'm
gonna piss my [ __ ] pants right already
get off PCH Ocean to the right
fire to the left yapping in do so Papago
I at this fairly large bottle yeah got
the old dick out yep
shoved in that shirt and it's a white
remember it's a white top yeah it's a
white oh yeah not skinny hi hey kiddies
looks fit in there so I just get out the
old baby bird yeah put the little dick
head right in the in the shoot there
yeah I'm peeing I'm like oh well this
thing's filling up fast just for full
iced tea here fast
yeah can't pinch it off no so I close
that thing up there it did splash yeah I
did did splash splash all over my hands
along the genes oh I can't stop peeing
no he's wet are my pants wet
Brian pissed your pants and I was a pedo
mask Martin a little bit
well my father we were in a plane my
father used to be an amateur pilot he
used to fly a little plane so he goes I
got a piss and he goes me too and he he
pulls out a bottle of some special
people big bottle not really
now my pop is a big man he pulls out his
piece and and he's not working with a
James that's what it's old days where
it's old man right
knowing no old minutes I've been here a
long time I'm a problem turtle he pulls
it out and I'm sitting there was him he
starts to piss
he's got khaki shorts on and he pisses
and misses the entire bottle and doesn't
really know this like I don't probably
welcome whether you're pissing all over
and he goes ah [ __ ]
and he just pissed and I got about 3
drops nabarro he's just pissed all over
the [ __ ] we got out and he had piss
honest front end on his ass we didn't
care he didn't give a [ __ ] I was like
you're walking around with a giant
you're holding your shorts are soaked
dude these construction workers that
weren't enough truck like well those big
trucks are driving by they saw my dick
piece they started laughing they
understand what dude I so when was it's
a group of girls you got a piss when you
got a pissed off it was so cool Dennis
can I fill the [ __ ] tennis can one
time oh I I need those big like get all
right I need a milk jug
I need no empty milk jug that's lonely
carry my car so when you got a really
pissed I'll just keep this old and I
drink a coffee that's just a lot brewing
dude it's a lot brewed the fires man
they're no joke
smells good right here down here cuz I
feel like it's it's not great like
somebody's burning wood yeah it's
getting there but it'll get ya you
should I'm telling me I woke up morning
that the news it looks like that we
remember this is the end yeah it looked
like that but it's not where everybody
think everyone always thinks it's like
Calabasas Woodland Hills Tarzan's Brando
this is so if you're not familiar with
LA if you have been a remember that the
Getty when you're on the 405 that's
where the fire this song if you drive
down the 405 the 405 on the left is on
if I you know where Steven Spielberg and
one and Arnold Schwarzenegger live
that's where it's at on fire yes that's
where it's at it's where the richest
people in the world live right now and
that's where it's pardon what it's
what's look at that dude so there's the
405 that's what your boy went down
there's rule five and then there's the
[ __ ] fire that's no joke bro I didn't
know any of this [ __ ] was going on I
really didn't that's why I take she went
Brian turn on the news I'll be late
today and I was shooting making believe
on Scalia that dude but here's the [ __ ]
in it I guess happened like 2:00 in the
morning like just [ __ ] popped off then I
turn on the news I hope it doesn't get
where my jujitsu practice how crazy is
that dumb
spoiled it all that just [ __ ]
supportive and I go up and said boy fit
all the time okay here's the question do
the firefighters like these fires
you're not saying cuz like if you're a
cop you don't just be doing paperwork
all the time it if you're a firefighter
you want to fight fires like they don't
want the homes to be burned I'm not
saying that they're out the chaos but do
they enjoy the job you know I'm saying
yeah I would imagine though it's such a
[ __ ] in those suits and you're
breathing but that's what you live for
your you're actually sign up you're
right here like if you talk to soldiers
they want action yeah they want a cow do
the firefighters want action like [ __ ]
yeah as a Marine the young marine I said
be careful out there any guys I could be
safe any is I'm not going out there to
be safe Marine
firefighters are heroes I love this girl
when I Drive by an engine sorry
truck guys for you guys turn now when I
Drive by an engine this last truck I
salute him I'm wave at him no badasses
yeah all right I love them yeah but yeah
wonder if they're if because it's fire
season and popping up everywhere now I
guess there's one Calabasas by where
daddy lives now so I guess there's one
over there now to
fires are how about for my kid when I
was a kid do snow days when I wake up
there be a snow day bike oh hell yeah no
school my kid wakes up he's miss more
days fires or fires its fire that fire
yeah fire my kids are on the couch
blazing about I practice this now I know
how bad you want talk about you doing it
I'm ignoring it and I don't want to talk
about I'm just saying what I do is I
keep my elbow to the ground like that
when I get a get no fires for you know
no fire traffic for you um no very very
little I don't know how I'm gonna get
home can I stay with you Brian yeah you
could say whether you want to roll I'm
just gonna keep ignoring your jujitsu
I'm a higen I'm a Hagin Machado student
now I had a private with Hagen Machado
and my rear naked and my guillotine sick
how was the air pilot let's knock this
out how was your private what why did
you do a private he gave Machado as a
friend of mine
where's most favorite comedian and he'll
tell you
that okay I miss favorite comedian okay
it's my pleasure my friends never smash
in your shows my brother he's been in my
shows a couple times don't never see him
Michael Bisping came to my show front
row in a row but like you know the first
booth littleman county he does Michael
Bisbing paying for tickets to come see
me with his wife and my buddy kmac was
came up and he comes up me goes Michael
Bisping Zinn the [ __ ] line I go what
he goes he's coming back I go we'll
bring him in his another pay for [ __ ]
tickets it was great he's he had a knee
replacement ya know and he has one fake
I fake knee yeah he's his body's been
through it there won't be a fighter huh
yeah you want to be a fire accessible
one oh yeah yeah did you see her did you
talk to him after anything yeah yeah
great he loved it he [ __ ] loves
comedy here he's the loudest laugher and
500 people on the loud dude yeah he's
clapping he loved it man he [ __ ]
loved it but he um he looks great he
actually looks great he's probably 225
by the way photo one one Oh everybody's
like everybody in the room is like this
they were like dude he's a [ __ ] house
he's like I I got almost you where I
know this I'm fat I go you're not fat
dude you're just muscular look at all
look at that is so bad look at that dude
I am it was like two times the size of
his other leg to you right oh yeah man
oh yeah
just a lifetime of training this is an
entire Laker just he did he always have
bad knees Peter did you know wow yeah
man
I think his eye looks way better though
it doesn't look black like it used to
cuz the oil it was detached and there
was oil in the eye now whatever he did
he fixed it I think and so it looks you
know it's different but it doesn't look
bad at all what's a it's a fake guy
here's a fake I take that I didn't know
that so he's point I didn't know that so
he lost his eye because he was able to
see I didn't know that that sucks
that sucks yeah yeah
so he's blind in one [ __ ] I have you
seen him he takes it up no and he's got
a new [ __ ] what is zero by the way I
wore my glasses my dark glasses as I
said to hide from the
mission I mean get a load of this check
this out look at this baby boys whoo
what I'm saying that's why I used to
wear [ __ ] sunglasses baby boy and he
puts it back in so wait this was a fake
I saw his eyes actually looking a lot
better he's had some work I'm an idiot
damn it I'm not in on it I don't know
yeah man I'm friends it it's [ __ ] my
old Bisbing and I trained with Higa
Machado it's like I'm right am I the
toughest actually you know I think so
dude am I the toughest after you know I
I will say I said he can said he said
I'm gonna make you a lean mean fighting
machine I said I just want to all I want
from you is I want you to teach me to
give I want to get to a point where I'm
given sob fits and he just started belly
laughing really yeah because of course
it'll never happen is that Cooper he
looks like it training with Bradley
Bradley and Brian look at us both couple
cuties only Bradley's much
better-looking than me God you ain't
like [ __ ] I look like a pig in here dude
no I mean he's got he's a movie star
movie star TV guy movie star TV guy
movie star a regular guy that's how
Harris he's the head of the field who
else does he get oh oh uh [ __ ] Syrian
blows Aaron yeah he can teaches
everybody but he's a lot of stars yeah
he's such a [ __ ] what his [ __ ]
schools in Beverly Hills it's right
there in Beverly Hills you know it's
great as Ruth Randy Couture Jesus Christ
is with some hot chick
he's a killer but I loved love the way
teachers named Jonah know Jonah Hill
he's up there with Jonah Hill - yeah
he's a [ __ ] great guy he's funny and
he's you know but at least you know he's
as good as a castle there is with Ashton
Kutcher he's as good as it gets
Ashley's looking a little thick trainer
to the stars man trainer with the Stars
um you know what I felt special I'm the
least famous guy he says Wow I'm talking
you think he tells Bradley Cooper is his
favorite actor meantime he genstat
and I Joe this the old shoes man he's
his favorite why my face
the comic he I heard that from gorilla
gorilla goes I gotta been heating to
show cuz he fathers knew all my jokes
yep
[ __ ] you none of our comics man don't
piss on my parade oh there is with I'll
bring heating up there right now this
girl at your head say yeah yeah dude but
I'm a comic I'm not a [ __ ] actor and
don't take this away from me
he loves my I'm his favorite comic yeah
he said it yeah no don't know other
lives with [ __ ] yeah so not famous no
this is [ __ ]
dude he's a badass though man
yeah he's a killer he's just a great
teacher little details and that's what
you need did you need the little details
I'm gonna start he doesn't like game
might get crazy with training oh there's
Frank no I might get crazy with Julian
Franco I miss I miss you [ __ ] sir I
might get crazy with it for real get one
of his black belts that was there Vin
Diesel back ah that's Bend easily every
accident every actor including me every
[ __ ] actor wants to be tough
look at how sad we are Mel Gibson with
Mel Gibson I guess you know some people
hey dude I don't need you and your get
it off only his [ __ ] else's alright
nah nah oh you thought oh you thought
you're special
oh wow wow that seems like he trains
every celebrity in the world I am
special or ginger his favorite and you
don't say that to anybody else
hey I'm very calming don't say it to me
needle there is no needles
yeah that was guys who's in Kazakh Stan
what was he doing there
he just does seminars all over the world
in 12 of the four yeah it's not a bad
life no hell no not a bad life he's such
as Machado's are great people hey John
Jacques is amazing judo jack I'm not
familiar such I don't know that my
personal base is such good I've met a
few of them but they've always been
super nice they're all good I've never
trained with any of them yeah they're
all just great just great well he is the
biggest of them all he's just the
[ __ ] house
everything he thought he added 355
fights jujitsu matches without losing
one
don't say fights though it be to matter
especially around real fighters yeah
yeah
it's a sport oh yeah it's a beautiful
idea
beautiful Jonah Hill hit he's uh there's
my boy is he back in out the Magno used
to train for him all the time love him
they see back there being skinny again
what's he doing he turn down the role of
the penguin he did why they understand
me I understand that why wouldn't they
ask you to be the Riddler you know I'm
saying I'd love to kill it I'd love to
if I liked acting um do you'd be the
Riddler and a [ __ ] heart be as I
would oh yeah I like I like I don't like
out of shape you know I like jerk Joanie
like think I don't like skinny Jonah
yeah he's a very nice fella I think
Jonah Hill is a hell of an actor he's
phenom I think he's in solanell good
yeah I think he's as good as it gets I
really do it you ready for this yeah you
will tell you nuts all right listen to
me listen me all [ __ ] aside take it
back now take it back I think you beat
Jonah Hill take it back just take it
back nope on his he could train for ten
years and I'm not joking now well he's
blue belt he shot the [ __ ] out under
Machado shut up and enjoy a nurse
Trenton I like him very much I was
younger now easy I'm a younger man I
love that guy younger I love that guy
younger I love jhanelle there isn't a
sport including jiu-jitsu
I don't care how long don't I'm feeling
rest Lee you know I'm feeling rest Lee
because I'm training now I told you I
already said this to you on text now he
can't die so [ __ ] shitty you're next
you're next private that bump Danny
DeVito's in there I hate to be stopped
raining on my parade
dude I trained now I don't just box but
I roll now it's gonna sting a little bit
what we can't get you in 2020 Denzel I
could text him right maggot Excel
Watson's book next he can write now time
for me no key and I roll he loves my
stand-up then give a [ __ ] about a Taser
dude stop it he's not a Stan stop it he
comes to my shows Michael Bisping
and he got me try I don't like any of
this it's all good dude tie me in knots
don't say any in what about you and
Bradley Cooper though I bet Bradley a
lot brother
oh dear I'm beating my bean I don't
think so really big kid but you know
I've asked Bradley he'll tell you he
doesn't want either way he doesn't it's
okay he's a Philly kid now I don't do
any stranger scrappy you know this
you're scrappy yeah yeah don't don't be
when it comes down to it I'll tell you
what when people are watching go hey
Brian let's you can be them do the most
pull-ups hey Brian let's see him in
those push-ups you know I mean that
competition of appeal watching and then
I go 52 year-old Brian becomes 30 year
old Brian he beats everybody you know
this how many time but I'm talking about
everyone well no you beat everyone when
you talk about your openers on the road
my open doesn't rotor better than Moloch
is did you beat them Monica kill Moloch
no he looks in shape he's a he's been
boxing since he was seven yeah no you
saying you beat him no no Moloch no he's
he's good enough when we boxed to just
he just stands right in front of me and
he was old and I seen I mean come on
well the [ __ ] it's a whole thing hold
it last night was fun though dude at the
show it was great we made a lot of money
for the charity the friends some nice
man I guess so nice Oh Dave yeah Dave
super nice and funny as [ __ ] he killed
it when or McDonald taller than I
thought a big man I know nice
NORs my son I know know me Norma I die
no I meant he's nice he's six six four
he's a sick sick I died on % yeah and
wide shoulders and the ones a young man
handsome guy - I didn't see you side to
leave on a c-stand Oh as a young man
very fond as a young man that's that's
[ __ ] that's x1 he's wait on that
I'm telling you meet him right on yeah I
couldn't believe how big you was yes and
look at that way young man handsome guy
look at that did what he wanted pulsar
gambler told us said went broke four
times I got you now what's your advice
we were talking about our vices
all of us is comics or misfits true or
false we're all misfits to one extent or
another thank God
which is why I love all my friends we're
just sitting around me you norm Rogan
adviye Adam it's just great
most people yes fun night man really fun
night Whitney Whitney Cummings yeah
wouldn't he killed it I love Whitney ya
know I'm so funny my favorite movies he
did Dirty Jobs ha ha ha with your boy
what do you think I don't I would be
like this one he just - he's going who's
saw who saw Dirty Jobs and people like
me and he'd be like here's your money
back but Don Rickles came on Don Rascals
great no he came out he was in Dirty
Jobs okay and he shows about yet he
starts destroying people cuz Bob Saget
directed that movie and Don Rickles came
out and he goes do you understand I just
came from the set of a Martin Scorsese
movie and Martin asked me said he said
Martin said where are you going I said
I'm going to do a Bob Saget movie and
the man clutched his chest he's so funny
here's Ian he looks at Marty because
you're a baby gorilla yeah yeah we're
gonna do it in a movie where you be
what's that you wouldn't do that
butBut Don Rickles came out to Bob Saget
in front everybody and this is when
they're doing this listen to me you you
you you're a Jew I'm a Jew you're not
giving us a good name you can't direct
you're terrible you're not talented in
this stick to stand up nobody takes you
seriously you do that terrible show
you're a snob lobby of crime I mean he
kills everybody he kills everybody
you're at you're a disgrace you're
embarrassing the Jews your baby girl but
again with Hardy he just kept looking at
him hey when the camera wasn't rolling
is look at you do you eat all the food
what happened
where's that where's that PA did already
eat him this killing Artie over and over
again because how did you make it okay
no I can't live outside you direct that
movie oh yeah
it's a terrible movie I love it man it's
one of the worst that's beautiful good
well I think right all right ya know
look at that there's Bob Saget Johnson
anus moving the job is Rickles still
alive no Dom did you ever see put on
Jimmy Kimmel crying do you ever see this
what is it
so hold on so Don Rickles for every
comic as you know is is such a he's he
could be and I'd say this now he could
you stand up right now and destroy and
it's pretty rare cuz comedy tends to be
dated but he was that good
yeah and Don Rickles there's a Comics
comic and performed until he was 91 or
something crazy
never stopped never stopped I've never
seen never stopped you years ago
wouldn't use it Jimmy Kimmel's done a
lot of time with them and Jimmy Kimmel
fell in love it's on Rick because it's
impossible not to watch Jimmy Kimmel's
try to keep it to hold it together
oh when Don Rickles died watch this on
live TV watch this how great was Jimmy
Kimmel how great is that up it's really
amazing what would a [ __ ] life you
know what would an amazing life to be
man well when you are when you mean that
much to people and you're that relevant
at 90 like I always think about people
who do that and what did he do he just
kept doing it for what because it's what
he did and it's what he could do there's
something beautiful about that man he
just spent his whole life making people
laugh that's all he did what a hilarious
by the way looks the same at 40 as he
did at 90 some people just let you know
the same wife forever huh yeah yeah he's
amazing he's just amazing his daughter
does stand-up right there really yeah
she's she's hit me up a couple times to
do her shows at the I think the factory
really yeah Wow yeah what's on shows
that's really cool he was he was one of
the great ones Don Rickles I don't know
this is TV family or is that it that's
it's real I think yeah oh yeah you're
right
oh that's Rhoda and the girl from Happy
Days that's about it my bad right my bad
Oh how about Brian I shot a commercial
yesterday what I'll have his gray eyes
it's a commercial for Sam Adams Samuel
Adams Boston lager beer and the whole
campaign is your lot to say but this
campaign yeah for sure
I mean I will air it on the show when it
when it drops should drop in November
but you gotta toast someone like there
hold the whole slogans like stop and
take him home toasting god you're nuts
so like toast is so and like who's made
a big impact on your life so when they
called me for the campaign they picked
five comedians and they go hey you know
I'm talking to the guys with the
creative with Samuel Adams he goes
you're one of the five we paid Baba and
he goes you know the whole campaign is
toast as someone who's made a big impact
in your life you know and your career
and your comedy career and then go so
think of someone well you know we need
to know by Friday this is on Monday he
was in we need oh by Friday
oh no I'm good I'm the guy I got home in
tokyo's really oh yeah guys I mean
everyone else is taking a Friday go no
no no I'm gonna
it's Brian Cowen here's all we love
Brian oh yeah I'm it's a no-brainer man
as far as my career Brian come's been
the most influence so here's okay well
well
so they shoot like the commercial thing
just of whatever all my stuff and then
like well the end we have to have Brian
come and you toast him and just you
gotta tell Mike not scripted just
there's no script you just tell him
thanks for what he's done for your
career and you guys toast and that's the
campaign like yeah no big deal I said
Brian's really bad with emotion so he's
probably to make a joke out of all this
so I don't know if that works for the
commercial he's like don't worry we'll
figure it out so we stood all day
yesterday I was shooting I search you
now talento you did I am oh wow search
units all day shoot 11:00 a.m.
Brian comes around five or six five 15
yeah then it's then you do the toast and
it's kind of you know it's it is a
little awkward because Brennan's gotta
tell me he's gotta say there's nothing
scripted so he's got to just speak how
important Brian is yeah and so but you
know were like really close we don't do
that we just [ __ ] around and laugh and
it's rare that you stop for a second
look a man in the eyes and go
hey you know you mean a lot to me I love
you thank you it's like and so well I
choked around the entire day like I give
Brian like this pretty weird you laughs
and then bribe your brain still worse
with emotions and that's well documented
on this show
Merrill I was retiring crying I lost my
fine brain cos you're gay man that's it
all right
God you the weeping giant yeah but yes
so I tell Brian listen we cheers and
Brian and just goes Samuel Adams huh hey
guys don't reference the beer guys I
don't know what else to say but we went
because you when you got there we're
[ __ ] around yeah you're messing
around and went from that and then the
guys now be heartfelt like yeah well we
had so much trash to talk about people
cuz it what Brendan I do is we're a
couple yeah Kathy gossipers and we love
if you want to get me on the phone
faster than anything or whatever I guess
I'm gonna tell you just get a text got
some dirt got some to do I got some but
you ain't you can't handle it it's right
hey Kareem hey man didn't know know what
to call faster hey what's so talk what I
want to know it's always about someone's
downfall they're so stupid
so he's some stupid I heard yeah did you
hear some [ __ ] chatty Cathy's they say
that's like gossip is ID in our DNA that
some women for sure women but also men
because especially when you go back you
know
Oh buddy last night yeah cuz we go back
in the day - that's like you know when
there's in a village when this hierarchy
ice they would talk it all so these
people are sort of in line he's also a
bonding thing - they say like [ __ ] like
when men get the other yeah you know
really women for sure but when they
start so gay and they started building
wells in Africa
us it had an effect on the women would
walk down to the river and as they were
walking they would talk and they would
bond and so these Westerners come in
think oh we're building you don't think
around the river and it [ __ ] up the
dynamic the gossiped I never became too
easy to do things at the well interest
oh yeah community is communities
everything I would argue a huge part of
the problem in this country is that
these communities that are planned
around the automobile and just over
around whatever it is that artificially
planned they don't spring up naturally
it creates isolation big
problem with people in this country is
isolation a lot of people are just not
working away from their family for sure
but then that where social media comes
to play and that's why you get such a
yeah but but that's up but that's the
only thing they have says you have these
forums you have these group chats or
have Twitter and Instagram but that they
can at least find other people who are
isolated then they form these groups
become you know they also find well very
very clear so much data on how different
men and women are with socially young
girls are socially as aggressive as boys
or teenage boys are physically they are
[ __ ] women as just as aggressive they
just experienced you know manifest as
well they they might daughter eleven
years old
she said something like God she went
through God what the [ __ ] was it this
she went away the camp and she said
something like yeah I used to be
friendly with her but not really anymore
and I go I go what do you mean she goes
well there was an issue and and she
turned to me and she went like this
she's 11 she goes nobody holds a grudge
yeah nobody holds a grudge the longer
than a girl it's a girl's world oh yeah
like that and I went that's crazy she
goes I know you don't understand
anything because you're not a girl
bang no again but it's true she's
already changing my daughter's already
already cynical already not remotely
interested in me already rolling her
eyes because she's in this world now
where to care about anything to be like
astonished to be affected is so uncool
yeah so her face is basically like this
all the time blood really Oh Hayes Oh
Dan and then ask me a question what does
she get excited it's me a question about
Catalina just say where there
did you see sharks and guys do how was
Kevin you see a lot of cool stuff yeah
yeah lemon sharks everywhere and leopard
sharks and ask me how big they were were
they big sharks or they were like four
feet
that's what I get all [ __ ] day all
[ __ ] day drive me nuts
if you have no idea girls you know what
boys are ten times easier and I'm sorry
I said a lot of people say she's just
not cute Steiger the cutest in the world
do you see him as a pirate with his
little bear oh my god he came down I was
working out and he was gone for like 30
minutes I'm like where the [ __ ] is Tiger
he comes down he goes
uh-huh I don't know where he got this he
goes hands on matey as a thrilled to say
matey is [ __ ]
hiccup are not so hands on maybe hands
on me boys boys get his beard yeah I
can't take it where'd you guys used to
color I had my girl use some makeup okay
it came right off
finally well right your girl oh yeah oh
yeah his Spanish better his English damn
high matey
so [ __ ] you so silly man I know that's
his third outfit already in October and
for Halloween and be his fourth outfit
yeah you lose your kids to the world
you'll lose them to the iPad and to it's
so interesting you die Pat we do healing
gets it on the weekend that matter good
luck you'll see it's just he's still out
he's so into sport to do outdoor work
like weed everything's out good
everything's balls and I'm good good
good yeah that's how I was it you know
yeah yeah but certain kids are like he's
a different like his name's isn't yeah
it's just that maybe it's gonna be a
artist sort of you know maybe yeah who
knows I don't know
yes I just expose him to everything he's
gonna get good at things like like I
believe in getting good at certain
things just learning the language of
things then you can make your own choice
I'm gonna separate him from his mother
when he's ready
in Holland they call it dropping drop
the child out in the middle of nowhere
what's from the movie 300 yeah but yes
piss apart and that's the sponge at
eight eleven twelve you come back as a
Spartan they make sense though that what
a stupid idea how he's gonna kill a
little stupid were they you know be
dropped in heels a stupid were they well
they made men but of course you know
it's less blood
you know as left as part of just some
pottery shove it yeah yeah you know it's
not the Nelsons you know let's have your
traditional else the movie 300 left out
they bustin on each other's asses they
left that out Brannon I just might have
when you're when you're when you're on
the road on the road you're on the road
you're gonna what
were you that's a real Road Dogg yeah
when you Road Dogg in my foot with 300
your boys yeah there ain't nobody around
jerk off and you could borrow your
buddy's starfish you can borrow your
buddy's [ __ ] you can bust in the
night there are there are several
cultures where where the new boy gets
[ __ ] by the older guys by cultures
mean Isis Isis a lot of that you want
join Isis yeah
do you know that every Tuesdays but [ __ ]
Tuesday well I'm at my friend who is a
high-level operative you know when these
Delta guys and he said that he's driving
the guys moving around the backseat a
lot he goes tell I gotta quit moving
around the backseat it's cuz he's just
[ __ ] itchy you know and he goes he
got [ __ ] in the ass last night my
buddy goes what because he was one of
those guys from that part of the world I
want him to say what country but he said
there's no he wasn't he was an ally of
the United States but he goes yeah he's
new he's young and they [ __ ] him I was
like who [ __ ] them the other not the
US of a guy with the soldiers of that
country that we were using for
intelligence no well yeah you got banged
up the old rump or pumper so the old new
guy new guy cuz with us knew guys like
noogies wedgie new guys just like oh
we're gonna be meaning like new guys you
guys I'm doing a spiel that peach show
us your star face hard chin why do you
have a hard-on do what I Jim came to the
show it's awesome Brea
big voice of course oh yeah he can't
come to no no too far I wouldn't make
anybody driving NASA because it isn't
Brea too far is such a beast life when
you gotta go Thursday Friday sit it's
the only time I've seen J shop kind of
break down usually we can walk for nine
miles we instead on an airplane delayed
whatever the only time seen him be like
was Sapp our third drive tabria
Saturday and we hit traffic yeah
Thursday Friday traffic awful
Saturday more Saturday afternoon traffic
human man I don't think I've come back
for Brea why this is finally the one
that broke I got you know it's got the
old self-driving swag them and I just
sit there I know but you're in Tesla so
yeah what about come on man don't you
have to be more respectful of my tests
oh do you know I got a co soon do you
know that we're gonna do a short podcast
today what time is it I gotta be on set
14:14 let's uh let's do some current
events see what's going on hey B you
know man I know you like to wear sweats
and I think fun of you but the other day
we weren't some sweat so it hold up dude
he's closed the gap between style and
comfortable where you're looking pretty
fresh yeah
looking pretty fresh yeah and your
public rack what you public wreck has a
number of different colors and sizes and
styles and there is good quality as you
get all day every day pants yeah it's an
inseam sizing okay
design details like elastic waistband
with internal drawstring to deep front
zippers but forget all that you got to
see what they're like you got to feel
them on now you don't have to look like
a bum when I sweat you go to a black tie
affair practically and street fight you
know I'm saying it still look good
because I got a lot of you being a
businessman
but also go to the gym after correct
ride my bike homophobic go to the movies
in sweats could be in first class in
sweats but you're looking pretty stylish
man don't just like a bum any more than
your old Papa sweats get some real
sweats looks good I've got to go to
public records last fighter day get 10%
off your first pair of there all day
every day pants automatically apply to
check out and they always ship free us
shipping and free returns they are as
good a quality pant as you can get plus
they look good if you want to wear
sweats don't be a bum and we're in the
old school sweat you get from your mom
look good with these stylish sweats they
close the gap between high-fashion and
regular sweats that's public wreck wreck
spelled re si.com slaps fighter for 10%
off you'll be right now yeah right now
yeah I've got UFC got NFL yeah you got
World Series yeah yeah hockey you got
basketball oh oh you can wear these
things crackin you can watch to make
money you'd watch all those bad on them
you know you say what's on your money
where your mouths at yeah dude put your
money my baby my book my energy yes
just don't stay on the sidelines anymore
watch your favorite fighters watch your
favorite football team watch your
favorite basketball team watch your
favorite baseball team and make Bank
with my bookie Agee and if you join
right now my bookie will double your
first deposit use promo code fighter to
activate the offer
let's promo code fighter to double your
cast visit my bookie dot AG today you
play you win you get paid
sorry guys no worries no worries man
here's the first one okay so this
costume went viral because a lot of
people are angry can you guys guess why
ah beyond inappropriate children's
customers backlash oh yeah I've renamed
Ramsey Ramsey
that's what I thought too but no it's
not no it's not I thought that though
it's because it's a little girl dressed
up as a bride people are associated it
with a child bride oh wow
I don't think it should be an opossum
don't put your little child as a bride
though but also who gives a [ __ ] that is
weird
it's we it's weird but I went back
everybody relax you can fit every little
girl wants to get married really right
like this kind of like don't or know
everybody I never got that I never had
that upbringing of like oh I can't wait
to get married and like you plan your
wedding with some kids do some girls if
some kids do like that I'm like girl
dress up like a bride yeah you know you
know we're not for child marriage
I mean nobody therefore things would be
a [ __ ] house well I am but also stay
in the kitchen wait right huh
what you said that ha ha ha just kidding
this costume is sold at Kmart and a lot
of people online are demanding that came
our actually pull all of their caught
their child bride costumes and that bum
you out
thank you guys do you think I'm Kmart I
go no I got a more I show a picture
right here like what is this Mike suck
my [ __ ] I want that one time to lea what
took
all this heat for making fun of sports
and sports fans on the 10 minute podcast
oh and he got so much we got so much
emails and he goes like this he goes hey
so I guess I offended a lot of people
because I know sports are an American
pastime and I know also that football
and basketball which I was going
especially hard on is something that's
very important to people because it
creates a community and I and people
love it and and I just want to say that
I am sorry if I offended anybody and I
also want to say that for anybody that I
did offend overall I want you to eat a
red Hey
eat a red dick eater I wish Kmart would
do that I would say just mm here's my
thing can you imagine if my mom did a
sudden never talk to her again if I
asked mom I said mom would you do today
well I'll tell you what I did do it on
social media
I attended Kmart to take down that
Halloween costume yeah can't be my mom
anymore now think about the amount of
free time and [ __ ] you don't have going
on your life that yeah that this matters
child marriage means child abuse and
torture and it's each year 12 million
children the same sizes custom are sold
or made off by the family out to consent
first of all the child marriage means
child abuse well first of all they're
not made off the Unites States the child
when the child was married first of all
when the child was very easily now when
the child was married traditionally in
countries that had child marriage let me
explain something to you they would they
would you'd have an arranged marriage at
six right but then you'd go back to your
family and then when you reach puberty
the man was older than the girl would be
then then you'd go and you get married
this was back in the day when people
would die at 30 so you have to hurry up
you know a lot of this stuff is you know
I mean I'm obviously I'm not crazy about
arranged marriages but just marriage in
general and I crazy about their the
whole idea of it you bet you know a lot
of a lot of stuff that we fall today's
from all such old tradition laws though
there is something about yes you know
yeah
what else will get okay so back in 2017
a flight attendant found out that the
two pilots on a flight from Phoenix to I
believe it was Oh from Pittsburgh to
Phoenix set up a toilet cam in the
restroom of the airplane so she found
out because there's a rule where if one
of the pilots needed to go to the
restroom there had to be somebody else
there in his place so it would usually
be a flight attendant one of the pilots
asked the flight attendant to come and
take his place just to sit there while
he went to the restroom because that's
protocol so this woman came and she sat
there and she saw something on an iPad
closeby where his seat was and she
thought it was odd and she saw that it
was him walking into the restroom and
then using the restroom she looked to
the other pilot and asked him what is
this is this a live camera feed from our
restroom and he said well it he was
trying to play it off as this is
Southwest's new protocol where you're
trying to like basically catch
terrorists or people trying to hide [ __ ]
and he said oh but you can't tell
anybody because we're it's kind of on
the down low yeah it's top secret plus
she didn't feel good about this so she
reported it and Southwest has been
trying to keep it hush because if this
got out nobody would want to yeah use
their services anymore and now she is
suing them along with her husband even
though her husband wasn't on that
particular flight he's suing as well for
$50,000 in emotional abuse 50,000 I mean
aim a little higher yeah something 9
grand for that with up for a few million
so you settle for a few hundos Wow but
also what kind of wait who wants too
much beauty or the bathroom freaks
there's something for everyone that's so
strange so here's the thing but what the
copilot you're in on it too both you
like this [ __ ] a weird freak really
gonna fly it might get me jacking off
well yeah that's you might be bored and
you want to see
well yeah cuz the planes are themselves
these days yes
cruising all they have to deal with is
the landing and that the take off in the
landing that's all that's all they're
there for that's in cruise control so
these guys like to let people take
whatever dues do so those bathrooms so
small even if you have a camera they
ain't seen [ __ ] they're not giant ass in
there you see big back it's just like
this mr. giant as you can see you see my
arm like this man doing cleaning earth
is he polishing it yes I'm just cleaning
my dick I'm just cleaning it what else
you got so have you guys seen this clip
it went viral yesterday just watch it
first and I'll explain it'll bronze here
would say your hair so that's the clip
down went viral and then people
proceeded to take photos Oh James
hairline look like during the game [ __ ]
so people are making fun of LeBron James
for a shitty hairline and they're also
congruent or like they're rooting
Anthony Davis for being the best homey
there is by telling him hey your hair is
[ __ ] up hey with but with the other
band on there like it like around here
oh yeah it's a um thing where you like
spray paint it on you spray it looks
like your hairline is thicker than
actually is and those fibers have those
fibers to just beat [ __ ] it's balling
the Brawn if I'm LeBron should go bald
give something well he's here it's not
like that difference that's a terrible
journey lava he lost all his hair young
age whoa yeah a lot of it love
testosterone going through his body I'm
sure like the guys do like this rather
lose their here's an ad here here's
[ __ ] up little bald patches in the
back - Wow here here's this you know
think how much I love 80 I think how
much money LeBron has he's seen all the
specialists if they can't fix LeBrons
or the president of the free world
theater house [ __ ] he don't drop tears
yeah you don't think he's seen experts
you can't do [ __ ] boy I feel like Trump
thinks his hair is great
you just think hey did you see him last
night I don't know if his current you
seen last night at the World Series game
no no he got booed Oh so but he's there
he's like this him and Melania and then
he he it hits them people are burning
seemed oh Jesus Christ oh you can see it
hit the the the way his face changes
when he gets booed you just see it hurt
I get hurt
this one here yep it you didn't realize
days boo but then then it hits them whoa
look you but he's like hey and they I
think he's waving nice controversial guy
has the president ever been booed like
this publicly walk him up yeah that's
just that portion of this dance
yeah well he's all and they brewing
single may be tough [ __ ] gig that's a
gay but also his his speech after you
know they took down the number one
terrorist in the world he died like a
dog he's a [ __ ] dog he's cowering it's
like yeah dude you are not very present
was ruffling up these [ __ ] he was
apparently in awe of how amazing those
special forces guys were when they
strong he was like a movie but then they
had like a guy who was worked for Obama
in was in the Intel on that he's like
it's not like the movie they the it's
over the top he's not seen like a fight
you're seeing outlines I think yeah it's
not like a movie yeah your proxy yeah
but then they're also pissed cuz he
gotta eat because he's not supposed to
give away certain time together made
these guys these are the shadow world
they're so [ __ ] amazing what they do
good Trump kind of he's like I don't
want to say where they landed but they
were yeah they're flying for about an
hour and 10 minutes
and then all the the intelligence are
like do they can figure that out man cuz
we know exactly where we killed that
terrorists and our ten minutes from
there well they can't go north cuz this
cant that you know easy sis
for people who are in that world to
figure out what the [ __ ] we're doing and
so and I know it's so fun it's just self
ridiculous wait yeah did you think I
would be like dude don't don't say this
I'm sure you'll say the right there's
all those things in and then he didn't
tell anyone you know you're like
President Obama when they caught bin
Laden he told George Bush he told all
the office like he lets them know first
then they let the public know Trump
didn't let anybody know cuz he said it
would get out didn't tell anybody I
believe I believe alright ready for
nother one huh
yeah this poor guy this I guess this was
released it was published from the
British Medical Journal of a guy who
would get drunk without drinking alcohol
so in his stomach when you eat like
carbs yeah food high in carbs yeah it
would somehow convert to yeast and
become alcohol in his stomach so he
would be like two times over the limit
auto-brewery syndrome yeah cuz is that
his gut biome is off so he's the
alternate keto kid he can't have unless
you ask you can't have you just drunk as
[ __ ] just have a piece of toast and
you're [ __ ] up so you had a DWI on the
way to work one morning suffered a head
injury and a drunken fall and I bet
nobody believes them either yeah it's
like I'm sure buddy knows it but then
they found out they did to us and they
found that he does have that
auto-brewery syndrome yeah damn rare
condition that's crazy
Dhoni does know that you get drunk so
it's not long
though what's up yeah all right here's
another so this is you know when people
see stories like this they always say
like all good for the hunter or whatever
but this is you know this is just a
hunter who was hunting thought he killed
the deer and I think he waited you're
supposed to wait awhile right like throw
you know warriors dead if it's down if
you you know based on the shot but what
I like to do it snipe him out and I
gotta make sure they're dead and when he
waited it out and then he walked up to
and the deer got up and then just
punctured him with his antlers
Wow God yeah dears don't [ __ ] around you
probably stunned at your thing
dear doing dear [ __ ] because when you
shoot it yeah I hate it's like somebody
died but also like uh-huh yeah uh-huh
it's the price you pay from being a
hunter you know that's correct that is
yeah that is uh what I'm worth what a
terrible way to go cuz a deer yeah I
mean you don't want that you know what
the most dangerous animal to hunt is
[ __ ] no water buffalo well what I know
the Black Death because Lola yeah dude
you got it I knew I knew water buffalo a
third time about America so I know yeah
well you guys say international all
right everybody knows when you shoot
Diavolo
water buffalo smell like dead what Oh
into the [ __ ] dark they go into the
tall grass you gots to go in there and
get him they wait and when you come they
charge that campaign said that he said
the most dangerous animal that he's ever
hunted is a dead water buffalo no Joe
Joe no Joe there's video of that what
are you laughing at Jim no I'm just
looking I saw when I was in Africa
uh I saw them Africa I saw a herd of
them and they just stare with their
black eyes into your eyes no one really
[ __ ] with them either like my lines and
stuff the Lions lie they well [ __ ] with
them but it's a babble I've never seen
water buffaloes when a lot of them they
die and some guys water buffaloes take
up beating like a big male and keep
going a beatin for like oh I don't know
an hour and their hides are so thick
they're full of blood but they're like
I'll be fine and they just the Lions get
exhausted they trot off you ever seen
when the line goes [ __ ] first yeah
I'll bite the balls on a line will take
its fat [ __ ] balls inside the [ __ ]
first kind of tear yeah what's crazy
those water buffalos keep on keeping on
well a lot of times a water buffalo gets
ballsy it's not a good situation but
they don't give the big males they don't
give a [ __ ] about lions use this video
like I'm gonna stroll by you [ __ ] if
we had more time we could watch hunters
have water buffalos know one of the ton
of the time they're gonna you know that
time this is how important this podcast
is I mean I'm holding up I'm holding
things up you want one more yeah close
it out yeah all right this is a this is
pretty crazy there's a family walking a
stroller down the street and then well
no okay and then this guy ran a red
light and would easily plow right into
him but this car came by just in the
nick of time it's when the red light not
yeah check this I mean to do it
no it was just a red light so see he's
got their crosses true now hey check
this kid scout Oh in the nick of time
hood thank God yeah that that would have
been such a [ __ ] disaster there's no
way they would have start there's no way
they can get out of time right mo they
would have died all of them Jesus Christ
the driver ended up being drunk and
tried to like a Good Samaritan try to
chase him down because he left his car
and then the guy ran up to the guy that
was trying to Jason and he stabbed his
card or her multiple times
this guy's crazy what a pieces oh so the
guy who did it he was crazy the guy that
did it was me yeah so they got him put
him in jail forever let the pieces
that's the guy right there - what a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
well I gotta go alright cool tight
little podcast little one kept it tight
tonight today so no show it was just
push it to the side that kills me well
we are we shot the [ __ ] when I got here
though we were being silly I mean kind
of dude we always record at noon though
you know yeah sometimes acting won't
wait sometimes acting like look it over
here Brian yeah here you dude it's all
good you're gonna be in Dallas Dallas
next week - six - Thursday Friday
Saturday Addison improv Dallas then in
two weeks I'm in Salt Lake City wise
guys hold on 21st to the 23rd now your
and you're not there next week Dallas
next week no bummer you're there in 14
days really two weeks yeah two weeks
well [ __ ] where I'm at dude 14 days so
two weeks I'm in Dallas that's November
14th through the 16th Dallas Texas can't
wait and love Texas we all know this
well-documented
then after that November 21st through
the 23rd Salt Lake City Utah wise guys
then just announced December 6 through
the 7th I'm in Kansas City never been
there and then December 12th through the
13th bananas New Jersey never been there
and then the big dog bort eiga casino
more data that's the big boy Atlantic
City New Jersey that is December 14th
get your tickets t fat K mmm that's it
so um I guess you suck my water buffalo
yeah whoa this the fun kid route